انقسمت الولايات المتحده خلال الساعات
الماضيه حول توجيه تهمه للرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب في قضيه دفع اموال للممثله
الاباحيه ستور ميدانيا الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن عمل بسرعه على ابعاد نفسه عن هذه
القضيه لا نتكلم عن توجيه التهم الى ترامب
وتاكيدا على عدم الانقراض في القضيه اكدت
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كارين جون
بيير وهي على الطائره الرئاسيه ان بايدن
علم بتصويت هيئه المحلفين من الاعلام
كلنا بمن فينا الرئيس علمنا بالخبر مثل اي
امريكي من التقارير الاخباريه
الجمهوريون يبان فيهم المنافسون للرئيس
السابق مثل نائبه مايك بانس اعتبروا ان
القضيه القانونيه تثير الغضب
انها سابقه توجيه تهمه لرئيس سابق بشان
التمويل الانتخابي امر مثير للغضب
كرر الجمريون خلال الساعات الماضيه الموقف
ذاته فيما اكد حاكم فلوريدا وهو اقرب
المنافسين الرئاسيين لترامب انه لن يتعاون
مع اجهزه الامن في القاء القبض على ترامب
لو كان مطلوبا اما الديمقراطيون فعمل
زعمائهم على تقديم القضيه على انها مساله
عداله ولا احد فوق القانون
انها سابقه ان يتم توقيفه في تهم جنائيه
ولكن لو رات هيئه المحلفين في منهات انه
ارتكب جريمه والمدعي العام هناك يستطيع
اثبات التهمه بدون شكوك فيجب توجيه التهمه
له مثل اي شخص اخر
والان تتجه الانظار الى مبنى المحكمه في
نيويورك حيث من المنتظر ان ياتي دونالد
ترامب الاسبوع المقبل ويستمع الى التهم
الموجهه اليه
الاجراءات الامنيه تصاعدت خلال الساعات
الماضيه ولكن لا غضب في الشارع ولا تظاهره
يستطيع ان يصبح رئيسا ولو كان مذنبا يجب
ان تكون جريمه اكبر بكثير ليكون هنالك
مانع من توليه الرئاسه
حفظ الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب على شعبيه
مرتفعه خلال الاشهر الماضيه ووصلت الى
اربعين في المئه من الامريكيين وربما
يحافظ على هذه الشعبيه على رغم الاتهامات
والمحاكمات في الغنم العربيه